when we move up the levels of  Entrepreneurship we need to make sure  that we're playing the right game and  that we're using the right metric to  measure our success our activity in  terms of number of activities that we  are doing is a very newbie measure of  success in the beginning Warren Buffett  doesn't say I sent a thousand emails  today he doesn't talk like that because  he's playing a different game if we want  to act like Billiards we have to think  like billionaires Jeff Bezos like woke  up at 4am today I'm saying this to  somebody who likes waking up early but I  also understand it's not required waking  up early doesn't matter not sleeping a  lot doesn't matter the few things that  matter are the inputs that go into the  system that have the most leverage to  create the most output that's it